Senta point of assay is the sacred  jingle shrine that it's been worshipped  for over 2,000 years - physically  orientate myself around such a sacred  central part of Issei community felt  like quite a big task but then workshops  and the meetings with artists and the  seminars I felt closer to you jingo and  the spirituality of Issei after meeting  those people that genuinely seems to be  a sense of harmony between the structure  and the calendar of events rites and  ceremonies and the general day-to-day  functionality of Issei community I think  the immersion into the society here has  very much being one with harmony and  thought